[Music]
foreign
preferred beverage at sporting events
concerts and toddry burlesque shows
and who places electrical tape over his
nipples perfect beer for blowing out the
pipes
[Music]
we are live on the internet we're live
on the internet right I think we're live
on the yes I got a thumbs up we are live
on the internet I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's April 3rd 2023.
we are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals and yes we are a half hour
late today the internet went out it was
not just our house it was several blocks
over here we were scrambling for the
last hour to figure out it was there any
way we could somehow live stream off a
phone some of you may have seen some
weird things popping up in your feed
because we were trying all sorts of
things I was actually supposed to be
on Fox News at like 10 45 that obviously
didn't work because without internet you
can't do much you can just sit here if
you're me and talk but nobody will hear
you or see you anyway we scrambled for
the last hour the internet does appear
to be back so we are going to get to it
I want to give a special shout out today
everyone was working very hard for the
last hour everyone remained calm nobody
jumped out the window it's like you know
we're doing a live show you want it to
be live special shout out to Connor over
here because the guy is pulling wires
cables electrical tape all sorts of
stuff and I said Connor what can we do
for you today you know you've been
busting your butt for this last hour
what can we do is there anything we can
do extra guacamole what do you need and
he without hesitation Dave I'm just
happy to be here that's the type of
person you want working for you you know
what you are getting extra guacamole
even though you didn't ask for it uh all
right let's dive into the show you know
what my show our show on Friday the
panel show was a pre-tape because I had
a couple things that I needed to take
care of on Friday so obvious I have not
fully publicly addressed the the Trump
indictment situation yet so we are going
to get to that in the second half of
today's show but I know a couple people
were worried uh were wondering we put a
little uh a little disclaimer at the top
of the show but if you tuned in a little
bit late or you just happened to see the
clips you might have been wondering why
on Friday I did not address it I was not
avoiding it at all I did send out a
couple of tweets about it and whatever
but I will fully fully address it today
and a lot of it's moving at the moment
it sounds like Trump at noon today
Eastern will be leaving marlago and
heading to New York so this thing is
just escalating in a crazy way but
Today's show will be a dissection of the
left in America they have lost their
minds they're completely insane and I
don't know why I'm talking about them in
this accent but they're nuts but what's
happening that's nice about this is it
is being exposed so in so quickly now in
in such real time
you know I'm always hesitant to say more
and more people are waking up and the
question always is well does it
translate into votes and how do you
change the culture and all that stuff
but like the bananas crazy left whether
we're talking about drag shows for kids
or the crazy politicians who were
socialists like it is bursting forth
there's almost nothing left holding them
back from being what they are and uh and
I think that's good news for everybody
and then of course we'll link that
directly to the Trump situation because
it's connected to that right you've got
a far left Soros funded yes that's not a
conspiracy theory we'll talk about that
too uh far left D.A going after Trump
these things are all connected these
people want power and they want hegemony
over your life and our political machine
and we just can't give it to them before
we get to that guys let me talk to you
about Patriot Supply real quick because
if our internet went down soon enough
you know society's going down so
anything's possible uh anyone who thinks
they won't need emergency food isn't
paying attention every day day the
headlines get worse and worse is the
unthinkable next guys well it pays to
prepare which is why I recommend you
stock up on emergency food right away
you never know when the next shoe will
drop Chinese spy balloon EMP disaster
who knows and when it does emergency
food will be hard to find so get yours
now while it's on sale go to
mypatriotsupply.com and check out their
popular three-month emergency food kit
right now you'll save 200 bucks off per
kit each kit gives you a wide variety of
delicious breakfast lunches dinners
drinks and snacks providing over 2 000
calories a day for Optimum strength and
energy act now and claim your 200
savings
per kit you'll sleep better knowing your
family won't suffer if the worst ever
happens go to mypatriotsupply.com and
you'll enjoy free shipping my Patriot
supply.com and now back to me okay so
let's start with the show today talking
about sort of the the out of control
ideas of the left and how they are
leaking into everything into society
whether it's your kids schools whether
it's all of the cultural apparatus
whether it's getting far left socialists
and and
authoritarians elected through the
Democrats the whole freaking thing uh on
Real Time with Bill Maher on Friday
night uh there is a journalist his name
is James kirchik he is a lefty uh and he
was sort of upset that the Tennessee
shooter who of course is either
identified as trans or was trans or used
the other pronouns whatever it is uh
James seemed to be upset I think he
considers himself a bit of a modder but
you know moderate if you say you're a
lefty and you're a moderate you're
probably still stuck in that sort of
confused ex-liberal thing uh anyway he
was upset that the shooter was being
misgendered by the news because clearly
that's the most important takeaway from
the events that happened last week
what's interesting if you've noticed
they are misgendering and dead naming
the murderer right they are referring to
the murderer by their given name not
their chosen name right and by their
um
referring to her as a woman as opposed
to what her identity apparently was was
a man right which is not the way the
media usually does these things they're
usually very particular about the
subjective sense of gender identity and
respecting that if someone says they're
a man then they're a man but in this
case they're not doing that hang on you
know what this person murdered six
people I don't really care who you say
you're you are you murdered six people
and three of them were children you
don't get a say well she's dead now so
you know but you don't gotta say in
telling us who you are and what you're
about you killed six people
[Applause]
all right so here's what I'm saying talk
about the issue without the so the issue
then well no because you brought it out
so you know okay talk about it so now
we're on to something else but here's
the thing
I'm a parent I'm a parent all day
I get to decide what happens in my
child's life not you not the government
not anybody I don't co-parent I had this
child I'm responsible for this child
anything happens to Little Johnny you're
calling me right as you should
80 right there that's Winsome Sears you
guys probably know her she is the
lieutenant governor of Virginia and uh
you know obviously behind Glenn youngin
and and her answer is phenomenal so it's
interesting because kirchik who
describes himself as a Centrist but you
know he's sort of like a liberal
Centrist like you can see his body
language and everything else it reminds
me a little bit of that clip that we
showed you a couple weeks ago that guy
John heilman the MSNBC guy getting
demolished by Russell Brand on real time
he doesn't really believe what he's
saying he's like trying to be concerned
about pronouns and things because that's
what we should worry about but meanwhile
there are I believe six dead people
including three children who were killed
at this Christian School okay and this
is what the problem is with the well
obviously the lefties but even these
sort of squishy centrists they're always
worried about the wrong thing then when
some Sears comes in she happens to be a
republican uh certainly a conservative
and she's like why would we get why are
we even talking about this let's talk
about out the dead children and the
teachers and what's really important
here uh and it continues she's she kind
of goes after Bill too uh over the
framing the way that we're all well
maybe not us but the way that many are
framing this whole shooting
so what I'm saying now is if I don't
want my child giving lap dances at
school by a drag queen I don't want it
done right that's happening do you think
the state should have the right do you
think the state should have the right
I'm talking about as a parent well I am
a parent I forget the state I'm a parent
this is my child I will make a decision
about what happens with my child I'm not
sure
it's happening you know there's drag
queen Storia they're definitely drag
queens reading to children they're drag
queens that are doing pole dances there
are drag queens that are in school you
you what bill you gotta read more
I mean she just smacked bill I mean
first look
kerchick over here and again I don't
really care about this guy it's not that
important but another one of these just
like squishy nothing people he's
concerned that the state should have the
right to stop drag queens from
performing for kids it's like if the
state doesn't have the right to do that
then what the hell is the point of the
state so unless he's a full Anarchist it
doesn't make any sense the state is
supposed to have basic protections of
people now I would leave most of that to
the states not the federal government
that's a separate issue here and then
you see how this is again what the
problem is with with the remaining
liberals they're like well no we're okay
with drag queenstoria where we just
don't want lap dances that seems to be
Bill's position like it's not lap dance
is it just drag queen queen Story Hour
as if that in and of itself is not
confusing for children and oddly
sexualizing it everything else as I
often say why is it that the drag queens
why aren't they performing at the annual
actuary seminar why don't they perform
for the accountants of America they only
perform either at late night you know
clubs or they they perform for kids kind
of nothing in between that does seem a
little odd doesn't it but Bill's
position sort of is well you know it's
just drag queen's Story Hour where
they're talking about the gender stuff
blah blah blah and it's funny because
he's always fighting against the gender
stuff too which is why the mainstream
liberal position just does not make any
sense anymore I'm sorry Bill I'll text
you after the show we can pick it up
that way
um but so you've got that and then she's
right of course we know they're doing
lap dances you've seen the videos I
don't bother showing them here because
they're awful
and they're twerking in front of them
and doing God knows what else and little
kids walking up to them and putting uh
money in their garter belt so it's like
it just the liberal position no longer
holds you guys kind of excused all of
this stuff to then literally come for
the kids and you've got one Lefty this
kirchuk guy being like well we should
maybe use their correct pronoun and um
you know maybe the state shouldn't do
anything about it and you've got Bill
kind of like well uh you know at least
they're not pole dancing but they are
pole dancing right so let's let's kind
of expand on this a little bit how how
this is connected to everything else
related to The Fallout of the shooting
before I do that real quick let me talk
to you guys about manscaped uh you guys
know manscape it's here with a deal that
you can't pass over this Easter season
did you see what we did there they've
got the tools to give you the
beautifully decorated eggs of your
dreams just because it's Easter doesn't
mean it's okay to hide those bad boys
always behind all that tall grass so
make sure your downstairs lawn is mowed
Daphne's really giving me a look right
now get yourself feeling as sweet as
candy by going to manscape.com and
getting 20 off plus free shipping with
code Dave inside the ball care Bunny
basket you'll find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose
hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
boxer briefs and a travel bag to hold
your goodies April is Easter but it's
also a testicular cancer awareness month
manscaped has partnered with the
testicular cancer society to bring
awareness to testicular cancer Men's
Health and early cancer detection
manscaped is committed to raising
awareness for the most common form of
cancer in men aged 15 to 35 and giving
support for Fighters survivors and
families impacted by testicular cancer
as part of their we save balls
initiative hold cow save 20 off and free
shipping with code Dave at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with
code Dave at manscape.com hop into the
best deal of the year with manscape all
right now back to me so let's let's just
sort of step back I wanted to use that
clip as the opening Salvo here right
you've got sort of a lefty confused
about all the issues more worried about
pronouns than the dead people and oh we
can't use the state and then you've got
sort of a more sane liberal and Bill
like oh they're not lap dancing but they
really are and it's like you guys this
is why we end up on the slow descent
hell nobody is willing to say the truth
as it is although when some Sears did
quite a job of it but now let's show you
how the mainstream media has been
covering
the issues around this shooter now again
it is still unclear to me and someone
can clean this up for me maybe we can
figure it out now if this shooter was
actually trans meaning had undergone any
surgeries what the level of medications
are and everything else we do know that
she was using male pronouns that doesn't
make you Trans in and of itself it might
make you confused about the English
language I guess at best but anyway
here's a little compilation of how the
mainstream media mainstream media has
been covering the shooter
there is still a lot that we don't know
about Monday's horrific and deadly mass
shooting at a Nashville Christian School
these these Republicans are the enemies
we don't own guns in this country Guns
own us at this stage this extremist
right ideology and it is sickening to
watch them try to claim the idea of
freedom because on the macro level we
have this incredible tyranny of the
minority keep our kids safe from our
Republican colleagues you as a
republican I think by your negligence in
protecting them we're going to say that
you're siding with the killers so maybe
it's not mental health or video games or
home hormones
maybe it's the guns raging Nationwide
Crusade against transgender people in
ways that are just dangerous and frankly
evil pronouns do not kill children trans
people are already more likely to
experience violence simply because they
are trans people Tennessee's already
Under Siege transgender Community is
terrifying so that's just a small
sampling obviously there's way more than
that but do you see exactly what the
media does because the media always runs
cover for the left and for Democrats and
for as Extreme as you can possibly be on
that side so a a trans it's unclear we
we just Googled it during the clip it's
unclear whether this person was actually
Trans in sort of the technical
definition of trans or what drugs they
may or may not have been on I mean so
some of this will come out and if you
found out that someone who just
committed an unimaginable horrific
murder was on mind-bending drugs and
testosterone do you think you'd have an
issue to be talking about there but the
media runs cover what do they do this is
about the guns it's always about the
guns right even though it was good
people with guns who stopped the shooter
but it's always if we could just disarm
the populace make them more docile than
things would be better you know it's
always Republicans and extremists and
Ultra Maga people and all of that
nonsense as opposed to focusing on
literally the person that did it and
perhaps an ideology that has been built
by the mainstream media that these are
oppressed people and they've got an
entire country coming after them and all
this stuff nobody the truth is guys and
you know this nobody really cares about
trans people and I mean that in the best
sense of it the way nobody cares about
black people or gay people because
nobody should care about these things
people want you to go about living your
life and five years ago we didn't have
this massive delusion this Collective
delusion where everything where every
day for some reason there's a story
about trans this and trans that but
there were trans people and they lived
their lives and they went to whatever
bathroom and it was what it was it was
only till this burst forth into Disney
programming and drag shows for kids and
now the radical trans extremists who
have basically taken over the entire
Democrat Party because everyone's afraid
to step up against them the one guy that
I want to call out specifically
in that compilation is Ali velshi uh you
know Ali velshi from MSNBC and this
thing where maybe it's not mental health
okay so you're telling me that a
mentally healthy person might just grab
a gun and start shooting people that has
nothing to do with mental health maybe
it's not hormones maybe it's not
testosterone everything else
it none of it makes sense everything
they want to do is to attain more power
over you and it's also one of the
reasons that they're so hysterical all
the time because they don't have a
principled position a principle what
would a principal position putting aside
what you feel about guns and whether
there should be any restraints
whatsoever putting aside what you think
about trans people whether whether it's
a psychological condition or whatever
you might be putting aside all of that
stuff what would a what would a sane
media be doing right now well it would
be going all right this person who
identified this way uh killed these
people you'd be focusing on the victims
first then you would calmly be trying to
find out a little bit more about that
person you wouldn't be obsessed with
misgendering or gendering or whatever
the hell they want to call it at this
point that person they're always focused
on the wrong thing and they're always
using everything for as I'm saying a
greater political end and they use
emotion to get there so speaking of
using a motion to get there here is
Elizabeth Warren almost crying on CBS as
she basically accuses Republicans of
murder
can you give a short answer to the
question about guns once again the
horrible shooting in Nashville I know
it's not an easy answer but will
something change this time are your
Republican colleagues saying something
differently behind the scenes about
let's make changes in gun laws I just
can't tell you how frustrating this is
our children die because there are
republicans in Congress who continue to
insist that we can't put just basic
safety measures in so we don't see any
behind the scenes conversation that
makes you optimistic or hopeful that you
know can I just do one in Massachusetts
we have tougher gun laws if the laws
that we have in Massachusetts were the
laws all across this country independent
studies show we would reduce deaths from
gun violence by about 70 percent these
are the lives of our children our
neighbors our friends and we just can't
get through it that's why it's
frustrating people know what to do
exactly nothing ever changes we'll
probably be having this conversation
that clip is so indicative of everything
that's wrong with everything the way
Gail King frames that there's this
shooting she doesn't really tell you
anything more about the shooter or maybe
why they did it or all the psychological
issues that they potentially had uh but
are they gonna now will they finally now
do anything about guns and then of
course what Elizabeth Warren does is
Republicans are evil they want you to
die and she says they won't do anything
Republicans won't do anything you know
it's really odd Elizabeth Warren because
last week I sat down with Ted Cruz and
you know what he told me he told me this
the number one way to keep our kids safe
is having armed police officers at the
door we know this shooter fired through
the door shattered the door with the gun
if there'd been a police officer there
the shooter could have been taken down
before a single child was killed every
single Democrat voted against my bill to
double the number of police officers on
campuses by the way the bill also
provided funding to enhance school
security to put in things like
bulletproof doors which she couldn't
have shot through here's the Democrats
view they don't want to stop these
crimes if you want to stop these crimes
you'd put cops there to stop these
crimes what they want to do is they want
to disarm you
now I always say This Is How They
launder the lies so you get an
interviewer Gail King who frames a
question in in a completely dishonest
way will we now finally do something
about guns as if the conclusion has
already been reached that this is only
about guns not about mental health not
about ideology etc etc right then you
get an answer from a politician
Elizabeth Warren OH those evil
Republicans won't do anything in essence
they want dead kids well then there you
go that is Ted Cruz who brought a bill
to put a police officer at every door as
he said I need to repeat everything the
bulletproof doors Etc et cetera that
would have done something that would
have done something and not one Democrat
voted for it by the way I'm not even
sitting here telling you that that was
completely in my opinion the way to do
it I think there's some risk over time
if kids every time they go into a school
they have to walk past a security guard
with the gun like there's there's some
psychological element to that that I
don't love but it's certainly something
and that of course is not what they're
going to address on mainstream media but
it's not just Ted Cruz Who's Making
Sense on this and trying to actually do
something about it and address the
causes around this uh Dan Crenshaw who I
also sat down with last week he was on
CNN talking to Dana Bash about what we
can do to avoid some of this stuff
the one through line in these deaths is
that they are shootings therefore they
are done by guns and Guns are the
leading cause of death for children and
teens in the U.S so shouldn't helping
save the lives
of children be a top priority for you as
a member of the House Majority
no it absolutely should be which is why
I say I would look to the thing that
would absolutely stop this which is
putting armed police officers at every
school I visit a lot of schools I do I
do talks at various schools it's very
rare that I go into a school especially
the newer ones and they don't have some
kind of armed police presence there at
all times so that's a preventive measure
that I know will stop this and there was
nothing like that in these last few mass
shootings there's no armed guards there
um so the answer is I'm just looking for
actual solutions that would be it so the
answer is more guns now the answer is
armed guards the answer is armed guards
right armed guard yes the kind of guns
that protect the president that protect
you all at CNN is it easy to get into
your headquarters at CNN absolutely not
there's armed guards there there's
single points of Entry I think we should
look at our schools as a place that is
precious uh and and have the same kind
of security that your corporate office
is do that we do in Congress you know if
we consider a place to be important
where our children go to learn every day
it should have the same level of
security as every other place whether
it's not whether it's a shopping mall or
a corporate office that's hard to get
into you're not going to get rid of guns
absolutely great answer by Crenshaw and
I love the fact that he turned it
directly on her what kind of security do
you have at CNN headquarters guess what
there are guys with guns there and an
awful lot of them and Gail King your
best friend is Oprah do you not think
Oprah has many people the only reason
anyone knows you is because of Oprah do
you not think that Oprah has many armed
guards at her many many Estates
protecting her but for some reason we
don't want that for kids again
I think there's a psychological element
that we'd really have to think through
about having young people around guns
all the time
um you know does it does it train their
mind in a weird way but certainly the
Republicans are not doing nothing and
the way oh so your answer is you just
want more guns
it's just so profoundly dishonest it is
just incredible and again what they are
really trying to do is just take the
guns here that it doesn't matter they
don't care about the dead Christian
children they they don't care whether it
was six people or a hundred people
everything is used to attain power for
these people there there is nothing they
wouldn't they I mean in essence they're
dancing on their graves that's because
they see this as an opportunity I'm
sorry if that sounds cynical it's just
how it is uh here's Justin Trudeau on
what's been going on over the last
couple days
transgender hate is on Full display
following the school accident in
Nashville the school accident
God
my government stands ready to protect
the trans community at every turn that's
why we're dedicating a day of
remembrance to the shooter who did this
because of Christians and far-right
bigots wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute this is not real guys
what
this is satire
did I just get punked live on the show
I just got punked live out of the show
no guacamole for you today wow Justin
Trudeau is you know what I did just get
punk drive on the show it's fine clip it
share it all you losers but Justin
Trudeau is so bad that we actually
couldn't figure it out but here's one
that's real and this one's from Joe
Biden this is actually real I promise
you guys here we go on transgender day
of visibility we want you to know that
we that we see you just as you are made
in the image of God and deserving of
dignity respect and support we'll never
stop working to create a world where you
where you won't have to be brave just to
be yourself again guys the issue here is
not that anyone shouldn't be treated
with dignity and respect and to live
their life as an adult however they see
fit if you are 18 years old and you are
a male and you wish to put on a dress
and go out to the world and even if you
want to have a beard and a dress or
whatever you want to do it's like
there's a community for you you'll find
it you should be treated there should be
no laws discriminating against you or
anything like that but they are
certainly
there certainly should not be this
celebration of this as it relates to
Children Jordan Peterson retweeted the
president and said this what you are
doing is an egregious sin POTUS
president of the United States
inexcusable and the point is the
celebration of this I guess that's what
is real seems to be uh
what this seems to be boiling down to
the celebration of a very Fringe
psychological condition again I want
everybody to be treated with respect but
that we have to celebrate it as if it's
somehow better than everything that once
was the norm is actually crazy and the
fact that it's directed at kids is
confusing children about basic things
look there there are Lifestyles that are
on the margins and societies should
tolerate them societies but the
celebration of these things is the weird
thing and again the focus instead of
focusing on that six Christian people
were killed three children were killed
that there is an activist base now
connected to the trans thing that is
becoming radicalized because every day
they are being told that there's a
genocide against them and that
Republicans are coming to kill them and
all that you're radicalizing these
people we'll have more on that in just a
second but here is uh Karen Jean-Pierre
cringe jean-pierrez response on uh
uh the shooting and the aftermath just
and one of the things that we saw during
the midterm elections is that people
don't want their freedoms to be taken
they want us to fight for their freedoms
and so it is shameful it is disturbing
and our hearts go out to uh those the
trans Community as they are under attack
right now
trans communities under attack it wasn't
six trans people that got killed again I
wouldn't want any trans people to be
killed the Christian Community is under
attack it's the Christian Community that
is always attacked by all of the
cultural and political forces right
what's the worst thing you could be a
straight white Christian man
these are the people they are constantly
demonizing and calling uh calling bigots
and racists and everything else let me
just read we got a real tweet from
Trudeau for you I'm just going to read
it out to you uh transgender and
non-binary Canadians you matter your
lives matter and we'll keep working on
trans day of visibility and every day to
make sure you can live your life as your
true and authentic self you deserve
nothing less than that you know you're
true in authentic self guys is is the
body that you were put in
right that's why I always say you can't
call this they always use the phrase
gender affirming care if you were
affirming someone's gender if you were
born a boy right you would affirm their
gender oh you are a boy you have these
feelings inside of you that that make
you feel like you're a girl well then
you talk to therapists about that but
you wouldn't immediately be having a
five-year-old put on drugs you wouldn't
be having these these really these
mutilations that's what they are of
these young people's bodies and
everything else and remember the clip we
played you last week where Rachel Levine
our Deputy Health secretary where he
goes on he lives Life as a woman now
although it sounds like he never even
got the full surgery where he's pushing
for kids to have these surgeries but
then a video came out of him three years
ago saying that he's thrilled that he
waited because he was able to have
children so these people I mean to some
level there there is a demonic element
to it I don't know how to describe it in
any other way because of the necessity
for these people to go against children
and go after children but speaking of
demonic Gavin Newsom is launching a
campaign for democracy I don't know what
the hell that means and if you think
this guy cares about democracy I've got
a bridge to salya but he's back baby
because they are hedging their bets it
does seem like
Biden is going to somehow make it
through this this ridiculous four years
and they're all backing him again
because they're all in on the Griff
together and the fact that the Dems
can't I mean the best the best vessel
for these idiotic socialist ideas and
equity and all of this nonsense is a
80-something year old guy who's a
lifetime swamp creature who has dementia
and has no idea where he is so I get why
they want to keep pushing biting but
they do have to hedge their bets because
his head could explode at any moment
right or he could fall down the stairs
of Air Force One or whatever it might be
so Newsome is clearly the guy there just
kind of keeping in the bullpen Newsome
could you keep doing some stuff sure a
million people fled your state nobody's
moving in you've destroyed the economy
crime is ramping homelessness blah blah
blah but could you just keep putting out
slick ads with your hair back uh and uh
we'll try to make it seem like you're
not an evil lizard person here's Gavin
Newsom on his campaign for democracy
let's be direct we can't solve a problem
without first identifying it the problem
in our country right now authoritarian
leaders who are so hell-bent on gaining
power and keeping it by whatever means
necessary that they're directly
attacking our freedoms in state after
State that's why I'm launching the
campaign for democracy we're going on
the road to take the fight to states
where freedom is most under attack or
republican leaders ban books criminalize
doctors fire teachers intimidate
Librarians kidnap migrants Target trans
kids Stoke racism condone anti-Semitism
Force the victims of rape and incest to
carry their attacker's baby where they
ignore the will of the people and make
it harder to vote and easier to buy
assault weapons
sorry he is such a piece of
there goes our monetization
it's fine I don't want to make any money
on today's show like he's such a lying
Dirtbag everything that Gavin Newsom
says is the reverse of the truth they're
condoning anti-Semitism they're banning
everything that he dare says the word
democracy or Freedom You Evil Lizard
person and people keep saying I've said
it before Dave you don't really think
he's a lizard person do you and yes I
believe he is a lizard person who has
taken the skin of a human being and put
it over his lizard face he's he's
horrible horrible horrible human being
and believe me I wish I didn't have to
talk about him except he's the one in
the bullpen if Biden goes down they are
going to figure out a way mark my words
they do not want brainless Kamala Harris
in charge of this operation he is the
one they will figure it out and he's
gonna to go no one's come guys you guys
were all out and about over the weekend
did anyone come for your freedoms here
in Florida you were able to you went to
a nice restaurant you told me you were
doing your thing went to a baseball game
nobody at the baseball game came
it's every single thing that they say is
an absolute lie but again you don't even
have to watch that and know it just look
at where people are leaving and where
people are going blue states are purging
people nobody is like I'm moving to L.A
nobody right you'd have to have brain
damage so I guess you could be a
Democrat and then you'd move to L.A but
nobody no brain damage Democrats are
even moving there nobody's moving there
you think try to imagine when when he
basically is saying that DeSantis and
Junkin and Abbott that they're Hitler
right basically that's what he's saying
they're coming after the Jews they're
coming after the gays they're banning
books it's all nonsense right try let's
let's do a little let's do a little
thought exercise here for just a second
let's go back to say 1933 uh Germany
right Hitler's doing his thing you think
a million people from uh the other
countries were like let's get over there
to Germany
it's insane
but the Democrats God bless them they
have a way of manipulating the masses
into believing things that are
completely untrue uh there were several
what are being coined as trans
surrections over the last couple days
these are the radical trans activists
who have been activated by people like
Gavin Newsom to make it seem like
anyone's coming for them even though
nobody is most of these people don't
look very good and probably should hit
the gym and ease up on the ice cream and
get better haircuts and perhaps get some
face wash but they are all going to a
whole bunch of capitals state capitals
they did this over the last couple days
in Florida Tennessee and Texas because
this is what the Democrats do right
remember BLM remember antifa when the
Democrats want to get mobs out there
they I don't know exactly how they do
that connection is a phone call made is
it in a list serve on on an app but they
can get the foot soldiers out there so
there were several trans surrections
these are these are activists radical
left Progressive socialist activists
going to capitals uh breaking the law
but you know if you're a Democrat you
can get away with it in Florida
Tennessee and Texas over the last couple
days take a look
[Applause]
protection noise
[Music]
[Applause]
we're changing showing off every single
day we came making our voices
find God
like what I have to analyze that do I
have to analyze this I'm not even
analyzing it all right let's talk about
the Trump stuff because these things are
all connected I'll analyze it for just a
second I guess that's what I do for a
living right all right I should
Reggie does play Clips I don't have to
analyze things anymore we'll just play
clips and I'll be like you think about
it
what am I doing here
um it's just nuts like these people are
unhinged they are unwell they're having
breaks with reality protect trans kids
says the guy with the scalpel as he
chops off your Wang
problem that's a problem these people
are out of control hopefully in Texas
and Tennessee and Florida as many of
these people as that broke the law will
be arrested because they're purposely
you have to understand this stuff is
coordinated these people didn't just
magically show up these things are
absolutely coordinated and they're
coordinated by the Democrat Party you
know when I did my last show for the
book tour I think it was June 1st of
last year when we did that with Governor
DeSantis in Orlando right in Disney
country we knew that leftist activists
well first off they protested outside
and they were screaming that we were a
bunch of homophobes and bigots which was
sort of hilarious but putting that aside
they they then set up people they
actually bought tickets to my event so
thank you very much we were oversold
standing room only because of you guys
uh they they set up moments when they
are going to they coordinate when we'll
start screaming when we're gonna push
towards the stage and we know that it
was done with several Democrat Party
activists here in Florida so these
people coordinate all of this stuff
together and what they're doing is so
Twisted because not only is it that they
want to chop off five-year-olds genitals
they are also taking a bunch of 16 year
olds 18 year olds who are who are
whose Minds have not been developed who
grew up with all of this nonsense and
algorithms and all the craziness and
they are telling them that people are
coming for them and they're not people
just want to be left alone and they're
not you know what the Banning books
thing is the funniest part of all of
this because there was did we play the
clip or I don't even know if we could
get to it last week because we were we
were in DC but we'll play it for you
tomorrow if we didn't play it there is a
clip of Ron DeSantis given a press
conference last week where he's talking
about what books have been banned and
he's showing you some of the things in
the books and they literally one of the
ones the gender queer book they're
talking about how to give hand jobs
he's trying to show this to people that
we shouldn't have this in schools and
the local news had to cut away because
they don't show porn in the middle of
the day but that's what they want the
kids to have that's how out of control
the entire thing is but speaking of out
of control now let's get to the to what
you're probably really tuning in to have
me comment on today
um because that's what I do here for a
living I don't just show you clips and
have you make up your own mind although
I do do that in a certain way
um the big the big issue is that this
Trump indictment is going through so you
remember two and a half weeks ago or
whatever it was Trump said that he was
about to be indicted and arrested on
Tuesday in New York it never happened it
was very unclear then suddenly the D.A
Alvin Breg who is a George Soros funded
D.A yes mark my words it is true uh then
it suddenly sounded like for a month
they weren't going to be doing any more
cases and they were going to just let it
go so it seemed like it was going away
then out of nowhere a couple days ago
they suddenly announced no Trump is
going to be arraigned today so here is a
truth social post from Trump I believe
this is from yester day he says I will
be leaving Mar-A-Lago on Monday at 12
noon which is just in a few minutes from
now heading to Trump Tower in New York
on Tuesday morning I will be going to
believe it or not the courthouse America
was not supposed to be this way okay we
all know what this is about apparently
he paid off
well it's a little unclear but what we
think he's being indicted for is that he
paid off former porn star Stormy Daniels
for sex but now she sort of said that's
not actually true we'll see but the
point is this is a complete and utter
farce right this is Banana Republic
level stuff they tried to get Trump on
Russia collusion they tried to get Trump
on the Mar-A-Lago doglets we had 87
impeachments the man fed a football team
McDonald's he drank water with two hands
this is just the machine going after
Trump you guys know I have been somewhat
critical of trump over the last couple
weeks and I know some people at the
campaign are not thrilled with me but I
100 without equivocation without any
inkling of daylight stand with Donald
Trump on this they are going after this
guy because he is the threat and
just think of the things that presidents
get away with
I don't know how about uh like lying us
into Wars where millions of people get
killed that happens every now and again
right like Hillary Clinton she wasn't
president thankfully but paying for the
Steele dossier that the entire Russia
collusion thing was was based on yes she
paid for the dossier it's real it's real
but this is what they're doing they're
going after Trump and and of course what
they're also doing is like Trump was in
a lot of trouble Trump spent the last
month before all this going after
DeSantis because DeSantis is clearly the
number one guy right now he's the guy
that people are going he's younger he's
more competent he's more relevant it
gets rid of the Mean Tweets he's got a
young family like he just feels like
that should be the future of the
Republican party they could have let
that fight happen instead they've
decided to suck him out of the gates of
hell and burst him forth for everybody
again and this is what they want you
must understand MSNBC and CNN are now on
the same side right they're on the same
side of this thing because they want
well MSNBC and CNN are always on the
same side of things I suppose but the
point is they're on the same side of
trump in that they want Trump out there
they want clicks and Views and all of
that stuff personally I would sacrifice
a lot of clicks and a lot of views just
to not have to deal with endless
nonsense but that's not the world we
live in here is Trump uh Trump's lawyer
Joe tacoponia uh I'm sorry Joe Taco Pina
that is quite a name on CNN saying uh
that the indictment wouldn't have
happened had he not been running for
president which seems fairly obvious
we are going to take the indictment
evaluate all our legal options and
pursue everyone most vigorously uh this
is a case of political persecution had
he not been running for office right now
for the Buffs of the presidency which by
the way the polls have shown since this
has been announced his numbers have gone
up significantly had he not been running
for presidency he would not have been
indicted I think that's fairly obvious
that had he not been running he would
not have been indicted and yes the poll
numbers are going up because people are
like wow the guy who was always
screaming about drain the swamp look
what the swamps doing to him so they are
increasing Trump's bandwidth right now
they're increasing his influence they're
bringing him back from the dead and
maybe it's because the machine really
wants him the machine is looking at him
going well we know he can't win he lost
last time he's not going to get a bunch
of new voters so let's just prop up the
guy who we know is going to lose as
opposed to DeSantis who we know can
bring in a cross-section of new people
right we look at the results here in
Florida and we just we just absolutely
know it there were all the Trump
deranged people who were like oh the
policies were good I didn't like the
behavior I didn't like the tweets well
congratulations you got DeSantis
um if you actually believe that right uh
here's more from the lawyer talking
about whether Trump will plead guilty or
not
will he have to take a mug shot
again Dana you're asking the questions
that I just it's not normal operating
procedure yeah it's all up in the air
all the all the Tuesday stuff is still
very much up in the air other than the
fact that we will very loudly and
proudly say not guilty
they're gonna say not guilty it sounds
like he will have to take a mug shot and
you know that that is going to now be a
legendary memeable picture for the rest
of time on planet Earth they are they
are making him into a martyr and again
you just have to I don't know what the
answers to all of these things are but
you just have to really think about what
their motivation is is the motivation
really to make sure he can't become
president
is the motivation to just make sure they
can get clicks and Views and we can all
be paying attention to that what's
what's so upsetting about this not only
is the evil Banana Republic version of
this in an out of control D.A and and
Soros funded and all that stuff that's
all awful but also like we've we've been
trying to not even we've been trying we
must move out of what has happened to us
for the last couple years this this
insane back and forth and this slow
descent to hell and all this stuff and I
really truly in my heart believe that
because of the model here in Florida
we've been moving out of it we've been
showing the country there's a way to get
out of it with competent leadership and
caring about freedom and not the Endless
Lies and all those things but now
they're just bringing the entire Trump
thing back uh DeSantis who was
criticized heavily by the Trump people
for not immediately coming out and
defending him remember Trump made the
original announcement on a Friday the
santis made his original statement on it
on a Monday morning he did it Friday
afternoon to Monday morning so I
actually didn't have a problem with that
uh DeSantis immediately when this was
announced that Trump was going to be
taken to New York immediately sent out
this tweet he said the weaponization of
the legal system to advance a political
agenda turns the rule of law on its head
it is Un-American the Soros backed
Manhattan district attorney has
consistently bent the law to downgrade
felonies and to excuse criminal
misconduct yet now he is stretching the
law to Target a political opponent
Florida will not assist in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances at issue with
this Soros back to Manhattan prosecutor
and his political agenda I mean that is
as strong as a statement as you can
possibly make what's really interesting
about that
is that DeSantis put that statement out
basically saying he's signaling to Trump
hey we will not extradite you meaning
you are in Florida you are a Floridian
you you live and are a resident of
Florida this is a New York situation we
will not extradite you we will not use
state power uh troops whatever it might
be to push you out so you got to go to
New York so he offered a force field
there for Trump trump has subsequently
after seeing that decided to go to New
York he it is Trump made the choice he
didn't wait for New York to have to put
pressure on Florida so DeSantis did
offer a bit of a force field there for
Trump trump did not take it and he is
going but the media is going crazy with
this because George Soros is involved
now George Soros gave money to a pack
that gave about a million dollars if I'm
not mistaken can we confirm that I think
it's a million dollars to a pack that
backed Alvin Breg he didn't give him the
money personally but we know that Soros
is putting in DA's all over the country
we know that he's done this in San San
Francisco and la and all of these blue
cities Soros is an evil evil
palpatine-like character like he's like
he's like Klaus Schwab level Palpatine
right
he is evil okay he also happens to be
Jewish now I don't think he's evil
because he's Jewish okay but somehow if
you criticize uh George Soros that makes
you an anti-semite according to these
Wizards over at the Morning Joe show on
MSNBC
he can't help himself Ron DeSantis
embarrassed himself by saying he was
going to fight Expedition charges like
he has and he say I mean again one more
Republican that really just doesn't give
a damn about the Constitution of the
United States uh and of course you gotta
yeah yeah you gotta just
what's this line look at the Soros back
now it's just Jews they're attacking
Jewish International Bankers it's what
anti-semites have been doing for
hundreds of years attacking Jewish
International
bankers and that's what they do they try
to blame everything on Jewish
International Bankers it's Germany 1933.
but why does Rhonda Sanders further
embarrass himself by saying I'm going to
ignore the Constitution and I'm not
going to extradite Trump to New York
already got demonetized today so look
Joe you are a idiot I'm sorry
guys I'm sorry I know you want to put on
a professional show you know you want a
phoenix or something like this
first off you know Russell Brand
remember a couple weeks ago when he was
going off on that John heilman guy on
real time about MSNBC he was talking
specifically about Joe's show how it's
propaganda do you also notice that they
had 10 people in those boxes what
situation could possibly be worth
listening to 10 leftist brain dead
clones talking about anything that is
literally hell for me that would be hell
if I go to hell one day that's what it's
going to be I'm going to be strapped
into a chair they're gonna have my eyes
like this and I'm going to be watching
10 morons on MSNBC that is genuinely
Health that's it it would not get worse
than that DeSantis is not an anti-semite
if anything Joe is the anti-semite here
he seems to think that if you call out
one person that represents the entire
group I didn't hear DeSantis say all
those Jews up there in New York are
trying to do this he's talking about one
guy who uses his money to destroy
Western civilization and he's doing it
all over the world through ngos and all
of these ridiculous DA's and the rest of
it that's what he's doing it's just what
was it it was a million dollars to a non
profit that then helped Alex the brag I
mean it's just absolutely awful but why
once again ladies and gentlemen why are
they really afraid of Ron DeSantis why
does the media this whole thing's
happening about Trump trump starts
attacking DeSantis and then MSNBC starts
attacking DeSantis so you've got Trump
and MSNBC it's hacking to say this so
who's the real threat and why is
DeSantis the real threat because he is
doing everything he has promised to do
one after the other he's just knocking
down
those domino pieces one thing I'll get
rid of Dei I'll get rid of woke stuff
we're going to get rid of we're going to
ensure our taxes stay low we're going to
build roads blah blah he's just doing
one thing at a time to ensure that the
free state of Florida Remains the free
state of Florida uh here he is a couple
days ago announcing the official
elimination of diversity equity and
inclusion in Florida
our legislature is currently in session
and they are going to be passing
legislation which I will sign to make
Florida the first state in America to
eliminate these Dei departments from our
University system
yeah
they say it's about
uh they say it's about diversity equity
and inclusion but in reality it's using
the University's administrative
bureaucracy to impose an ideological
agenda
policy
effective communication competency
that's what the guy is doing and that's
why they want you to think this is like
1933 Germany because the thing they fear
most is that they will lose their power
that you will watch them and be like boy
that Joe is an idiot and these 10 morons
in these boxes they are lying to us
about absolutely everything but they are
so deep on in it and it what's ironic
about it is man you guys you always have
these moments where you can save
yourself no matter how deep in the BS
you go and for all of these people who
had Trump Arrangement syndrome so their
excuse was I can't deal with Trump
because of the Mean Tweets and the way
he talks and he grabbed them by the this
and blah blah blah but the policies I
like well DeSantis is actually giving
you the policies so it's like they
shouldn't hate him right most of these
people shouldn't hate him if you if you
were a sane liberal if you were saying
old school liberal you might be going
all right well maybe there's a bit much
for what I like but like this guy's
pretty good and he's doing a lot of
seemingly decent stuff and as a decent
liberal I hate the woke stuff and he's
the only one fighting it
but they're not decent people and
they're just not I'm sorry I'm sorry
they're just not he knows exactly what
he is doing for that poorly rated show
10 people in a box can you imagine all
right so what do you do guys you fight
back on policy that's what Rhonda
DeSantis is doing another way you can
fight back is using comedy and this is
really beautiful this was the day that
we left DC I wish I had seen this in
person uh you know the account on Tick
Tock or the well it's an account on Tick
Tock but also big on Twitter Libs of
tick tock so this is a girl her name is
Haya raychik and she was uh she was
doxed ultimately she did this as an
anonymous account all she did really was
repost videos that other people had put
up just exposing these trans activists
like the crazy things they were saying
the teachers who were saying they were
changing pronouns of their students
that's all she did she didn't add
commentary she was never in these videos
she got banned a gajillion times anyway
aoc's gone after her for crazy stuff she
bumped into AOC at the Capitol and this
is wonderful
to your office
yeah
[Music]
thank you
super transphobic and I never want to
share space with you that's a
congresswoman like that's someone we're
supposed to take seriously she's
transphobic she has an irrational fear
of trans people if you go to the libs of
tick-tock account she's reposting what
they say that's all she's doing so if
you think someone's transphobic it would
be the people of the videos that she in
the videos that she's reposting it would
be the trans people themselves that's
all she does so that's one a great job I
hire right there it's not it's not that
fun to get right up in their face and
call them out like that and the way she
scurries away like a little rat so okay
so what do you do you talk about policy
Ron DeSantis you use a little comedy and
you get in their face like Libs of tick
tock you can also speak truth to power
this is a really nice moment Marjorie
Taylor green uh going after leswell not
even going after Leslie Saul she's just
laying out the truth here on CBS and
that doesn't happen very often so Leslie
Stahl has nothing to say
and things she says that are over the
top like the Democrats are a party of
pedophiles
I would definitely say so they support
grooming children they are not
pedophiles why would you say that
Democrats Democrats support even Joe
Biden the president himself supports
children being sexualized and having
transgender surgeries sexualizing
children is what pedophiles do to
children
okay
okay because it is true when you
sexualize children that is what
pedophiles do I'm pretty sure it's baked
in there and the definition of the thing
and why is it that to get us to where we
started today that they want drag queens
who until five years ago were only at
late night clubs did you watch the bird
cage remember the bird cage great movie
20 something years ago Robin Williams
remember that do you think they had kids
in the audience and if they did everyone
would think it was ridiculous but Leslie
stall doesn't know what to say she says
these evil things and then it's like
yeah it's all kind of true uh so what do
we have to do guys what do we have to do
I would say we have to crush the media
now the media must be crushed and we can
either do that by reforming Tech or
building new tech platforms the the
corporate press look they are never
going to stop I've really come around to
this this concept ABC CBS NBC wash of
all these things New York Times it's
never going to stop there is a short of
them just collapsing all together right
like people just tuning out all together
they're never going to stop they they
have the host has been infected right
alien the host has taken over it
gestated in their body and now the alien
has burst forth these guys are never
going to turn around but we do have some
chances one of the chances that we have
right now is because as you know because
of Elon Musk who has done an incredible
job bringing some transparency to
Twitter so we now know the government
was involved in silencing people we know
that radical leftist activists were
there silencing people including me and
most likely including you whether you
know it or not
and that is great one of the things that
Elon is doing as of two days ago is he
is removing all the Legacy blue checks
now you guys are on Twitter you know
about the blue check the blue check was
this way of knowing that someone was
someone so I got a blue check years ago
if you if you were someone of a certain
amount of notoriety you were an actor or
an athlete or a pundit or something you
could get the blue check and that just
meant you are you unfortunately over
years it became completely abused
because activists that were working at
Twitter were giving it to some people
who didn't deserve it they were stopping
other people always conservatives from
having it so it became complete nonsense
so as of two days ago the old school
blue check does not exist anymore and
this is a beautiful thing because it's
it's democratizing Twitter that no one
will just be thought of as an expert in
something because they got a blue check
given to them by some activist at a tech
company 10 years ago the New York Times
which charges a monthly subscription to
get its crap fantastic newspaper has
announced that it will not pay the I
think fourteen dollars a month to get
the blue check anymore so the New York
Times is no longer verified that's right
so it will not come up in verified
mentions they're they're you know they
claim to have 54.9 million followers as
you see there their tweets barely get a
thousand retweets which means that
basically 54.9 million people ignore
everything that they say and uh here's
Elon Musk on on just that he wrote the
real tragedy of the New York Times is
that their propaganda isn't even
interesting so people are being red
pilled right that's what's happening
right in front of our faces and again we
just you can't take it as a win like oh
look it's all great because the machine
is never going to stop they will try to
do Duran DeSantis what they're doing to
Donald Trump and we have to defend I
would say we have to give everything we
can to defend Donald Trump from this
madness because as he has pointed out it
will come for him now but he's just the
one standing in the way eventually it'll
come from everybody I think we have to
defend a guy like Ron DeSantis when it
comes to the right policies
and how about this you have to defend
your kids you have to defend the people
in your local community and everything
else uh because they are just not going
to stop we got a little more for you
here uh this is Joe Rogan he had Michael
schellenberger on again schellenberger
of course is the a lifelong Lefty
liberal I've had him on the show a
couple times uh he is one of the guys
who did the original Twitter files uh
they started talking about Elon and
truth and conspiracy theories and why
Twitter sort of is an important place
now to get some of this stuff cleaned up
we were talking about this last night
that you know when I was texting Elon
about all this stuff he he was like he's
hilarious he's like turns out all the
conspiracy theories were true LOL
[Laughter]
knuckling the whole
scary I guess having 200 billion dollars
really puts a nice cushion on like the
repercussions for whatever the you
do other than him getting assassinated
and he has publicly stated that I'm not
suicidal and I think he's legitimately
concerned like that could be something
that happens to him his security tells
amazing it should be yeah yeah it should
be Beyond me yeah you said Iron
Man Guardian even better than your
security still man I'll have to step
here stop after this interview
look Rogan has got the biggest podcast
on the planet millions and millions of
people listening to each week and
millions and millions of people are
listening to Elon Musk and they're on
the same side of this thing and Elon
Musk who is a lifelong Democrat has said
he would vote for Ron DeSantis and it's
not just about the political part of
this it is that truth as I always say
has been a time release pill and enough
of us are waking up we just got to keep
waking up more people and then vote
these people out vote out the Liars take
away their power if you haven't seen my
interview yet with Kevin McCarthy we
just put it up over the weekend
hour-long interview that we did at the
at the Capitol one of the things he
talks about
he says look we Republicans we have
power in the house we can't do
everything but one of the things we can
do is defund things we can defund
departments we can make sure that Dei
programs aren't getting the money that
they should get and eventually they go
away like those are the type of things
that we should all be supporting so what
we need what we need are the remaining
how many times we have to drive you over
the head with it guys the remaining
liberals Rogan Elon Musk shellenberger
they have to vote the right way and I I
think maybe this will be the chance on
the Trump thing complicates it because
they will they most of them will not
vote for Trump certainly right Bill
Maher is not voting for Trump Rogan's
probably not voting for Trump
schellenberger's probably not voting for
Trump but they might vote for DeSantis
and without even making this all
political what's this really about it's
about our ability to communicate ideas
uh honestly with each other without
algorithmic manipulation being able to
say what we think is right being able to
challenge the system being able to
communicate with other people without
thinking that the government is actually
reading all of our texts and all of
those things
and Russell Brand was on Bill Maher's
podcast which debuted last night and
they talked about Free Speech they
talked about Rumble and this Dave Rubin
guy so I had to throw this in
what is Rumble now I'm sorry media uh
stupid it's essentially a competitor to
YouTube which has made its raise on
Detra non-censorship that has been taken
up initially by a lot of right uh like
you'd have to say a right-wing uh voices
uh but is doesn't have any skin in the
game with regard to like all the kind of
content that is put out except for that
you continue to own your content and you
know you can say what you want you can
talk about what you want and like for me
like freedom of speech doesn't mean
freedom of speech to condemn and
criticize people it means freedom of
speech to attack establishment and look
for ways to bring people together Dave
Rubin Dave rubin's on there yeah I know
Dave's been on it's not his company
though but it is owned I believe locals
which is the sort of membership aspect
of Rumble which is essentially like
YouTube he's been here love love I love
him yeah he's a great guy yeah and we
don't agree politically no but but we
laugh about it it's it's
yeah and the here's the problem with
Where We Are
media wise as it especially Free Speech
you know as Comics we adore free speech
I it's it's my life blood I couldn't be
there I'm so grateful to the people who
came before me who were Martyrs for free
speech you know there was no doubt in my
mind who the champions of free speech
were and and also the threat and the
threat was all on the right yeah and the
Champions were on the left and that's
not how I feel now so when people say
like oh why are you harder on the left
well that's one of the big reasons I
just mentioned Lenny Bruce so I'm going
to say that that's a sign from the
universe and by the way Dave rubin's
always trying to convince me about the
universe which I find amusing but um I'm
going to pretend there's such a thing is
the universe
and say that uh Lenny Bruce you know he
forgot to like be an Entertainer because
he was so passionate right I don't want
that to happen to you I don't think it
will it never has you proved that like
not just here but on real time today it
was just like
you know you bring him in
and just uh that's you know I don't know
why I'm anointing myself as the person
to give you advice you probably don't
need
had a real come to Jesus moment as they
say what if instead of trying to convert
Bill Maher anymore on which way he
should vote I've made my point I think
you guys get my point and hopefully bill
will come around I'm sort of losing hope
to a certain degree and Bill I
appreciate you and I I thank you for the
kind words what if really because as he
said Dave rubin's always trying to get
me to believe in the universe what if my
real goal now with Bill Maher should be
that he will one day do a prageru video
why I left atheism maybe that will be
the Dave Rubin as we roll into Passover
and Easter maybe that's the Dave Rubin
shift because there are things happening
in the universe and we are connected in
ways that we cannot fully understand and
you end up as a Believer whether you
believe it or not but that's a whole
other topic for a whole other show
we didn't talk much about Joe Biden
today so let's end with one little Joe
Biden thing how was Joe Biden doing this
past weekend
do you realize all Joe Biden is capable
of doing at this point is telling people
not to jump so don't commit suicide when
you see me that's a big one for him and
also coming downstairs when there's ice
cream this thing with the ice cream
where he wanders downstairs they don't
know you know he's supposed to be it
they can be talking Ukraine they could
be talking about the economy they could
be talking about latest trans nonsense
he comes downstairs I'm just down here
for the ice cream I love chocolate chip
ice cream you think I'm kidding I'm not
kidding
may God help us all I hope you've
enjoyed Today's show it was a lot it was
it was an emotional roller coaster today
uh I want to say once again how great it
was uh seeing a bunch of you guys in DC
last week it was really just fantastic
and it was great having drinks and some
tacos with you and a whole bunch more
and our interviews from DC are all
rolling out so Kevin McCarthy full is up
right now Ted Cruz who did the live show
with me on Wednesday that's up already
uh chip Roy and Thomas Massey we did
that one together that's up right now
Lauren bobert that's up right now Matt
Gates that's up right now Dan Crenshaw
that's up right now who's going up today
Byron Donald's and Jim Jordan today
we've got Ron Johnson still coming we've
got a whole bunch of other ones so stay
tuned for all of that we leave you with
the clown like George Soros funded D.A
in New York goodbye
yeah they're they're you are right we
got a two standards of Justice the
Harvey Weinstein Jeffrey Epstein being a
rich old white man has allowed you to
fade accountability in Manhattan that
includes Trump and his children
[Music]
thank you